[Music]
so I'm glad to be here today talking a
little bit about where I work so in full
transparency the conversation is powered
by robitussin and cough drops so I can't
be held accountable for anything I say
I brought my notes up to help me out a
little bit with that so please work with
me and bear with me so I am the CIO my
name is David Shia and I'm the CIO of
the largest property management
organization in the world think of like
Jones Lang LaSalle we're bigger than
that
I am also the CIO of the largest fleet
in the world so think of ups is big
great big fleet or coca-cola or Avis or
places like that our fleet is bigger
than all of that
we are the purveyor of the largest
collections of arts and antiquities in
the world we we're the one of the
biggest design and construction
companies in North America so think
widening Turner
or Clark construction we do those bodies
of work we we do all of this effectively
with technology and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about partnership and the
effective use of technology at the end
of this discussion but we do this on
behalf of you many of you in this space
if you're US citizen or a visitor to the
United States you're part of who we do
this for so who are we where the United
States General Services Administration
and we do all this on behalf of the
citizens and visitors of the United
States as well as the federal agencies
that support operations in the federal
space so that's a pretty picture of our
place that's one of the many buildings
that we manage and and control along
with the Pentagon and the White House
and others like that so all of this this
disparate business mission we're
effectively the back office of the
United States we look after of land and
buildings physical needs our workers our
property managers their purchasing
agents their policy writers we write
policy for the entire federal government
their technologists we provide
technology for the federal government we
do this on behalf of our federal
partners so that our federal partners
can focus on their primary mission areas
which are protecting our borders and
accelerating the mission to Mars or
curing cancer we do this kind of mundane
work so that they can focus on their
primary mission areas because we've been
doing that for a long time
we've become a proving ground a test
ground for new and enabling technologies
so that what we can try before we buy
and try before we use in GSA we can then
scale across the rest of government so
talking about that digital
transformation role you know because
we've used technology as an enabler for
a fair amount of time we've been able to
take what we've learned internally and
scale that through our Federal
Acquisition service were the purchasing
agents of the federal government or
through Internet of Things with our
building automation technologies and
we'll scale that through government
taking our IOT learnings and moved on
from there let's go to the next one so
how do we do this in this role we we do
a few things one we try new technologies
we track world-class talent into our
organization and we do this for a couple
of reasons
we're steward of taxpayer dollars we're
spending your money a shareholder when
they make an investment in a company
they're going into that knowing the
bacon they can potentially lose that
money you citizens you're not making
that investment we're obligated to do
well for you that is a that's a
significant influence on how we do our
technology and why we do our technology
because of that because we're dealing
with taxpayer dollars we share
everything we share a code we share our
play books we share our configurations
we share Talent
we shower infrastructure because we're
doing this with your dollars in addition
to being able to share everything the
ideation that we do the builds of our
minimally viable products how we deliver
how we determine what works and what
doesn't work we we get some really good
outcomes by doing that by rapidly
iterating to things that work and
rapidly pivoting away from things that
don't that allows us to be sort of a
training center for effective use of
technology not only in the federal
government but elsewhere some examples
are the people from my team GSA IT are
now the chief technology officer for
Department of Homeland Security or run
the federal practice at Salesforce or
run the federal practice at box because
they learn what they can do what the art
of the possible is in federal government
here and then export that out elsewhere
some of the results of this mindset this
innovation mindset are up on the screen
we've been able to rationalize our
applications down to about 20% the way
we deliver we've been able to save 17.8
percent of our costs while also
increasing employee satisfaction with
what we do and how we do it
that's over 100 million dollars
recurring annually that we've been able
to save while driving hire a more
effective adoption of technologies and
my customer satisfaction rate is 91% let
that sink in for a minute 91% in the IT
space very proud of that so so to the
comms team this is where I'm gonna kind
of go off script a little bit so you're
free to you know go get a cup of coffee
or something like that so tarik at the
beginning talked about partnership and
that's where I want to end this
conversation because partnership is key
a part and parcel to everything that we
do when we started our transformation
play in 2011 there were zero agencies in
the federal government that we're using
cloud-based email zero and so when we
said we need to find a lever to drive
transformation into the federal gun
Herman we had to be very intentional
about what we did because the technology
piece frankly is the easy part the hard
parts organizational change management
driving adoption of of new technologies
into a new space and so we had to be
very intentional about what partner we
chose we happen to choose Google so we
partnered with Google to flip from 17
mail systems into a cloud-based Gmail
system so all some really good outcomes
there and what that did is allowed me to
do two things one in my organization say
look if you transform it's not the end
of your business your world your
business world we'll be able to continue
to grow and thrive and that provided a
springboard to the next step and we said
ok what's the next logical target you
know we had employees storing data on
their laptops and on their phones and in
any space where they could possibly find
it we said well let's put a controlled
environment there and move that out to
the cloud so we moved to Google Drive
and I had all 16,000 of our employees
move their data out to Google Drive
really great outcomes people saw they
could still access their stuff they
could get to it from anywhere and and
then and then they saw those great
outcomes and then we move to Google Docs
and then we moved to Google scripting to
allow us to do business process and then
we moved on to Google cloud amongst
other clouds and so that lever that's
the thing I want to leave everybody with
when you're choosing your partners your
transformation agents in your
organizations choose very carefully
because they can be the one thin line
the discriminator between success and
failure in that regard we're super proud
that we used Google as that primary
transformation agent from the very
beginning that's it thank you very much
[Music]